Trump after his arraignment he swung by
Versa Versailles Cafe Versailles if
you're French and he swings by and he
chats not with the political Elites but
with ordinary people down there in
Florida and he says stay strong we're
gonna fight this we have a country
that's got no borders we have a country
that's got nothing but problems We're a
nation and Decline and then they do this
thing and you see where the people are
we love the people and you see where
they are you see the crowds and
everything else we have a country that
is in Decline like never before and we
can't let it happen I'm gonna make a
little speech tonight in Bedminster I
hope you're going to be there and you
start tomorrow
you can come too if you want
thank you everybody thank you that's why
a lot of Republicans still support him